BACK MONDAY, 8:00 P.M.
HAVE THE BEST WEEKEND WITH THE
ONES YOU LOVE.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY,"
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAY OUT OF
CONTROL.
THEY'RE DECLARED WAR ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
DRIVEN BY A BLIND, UNYIELDING,
PSYCHOTIC RAGE FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
AND DEMOCRATS AND THE
COLLABORATORS IN THE MOB WILL DO
ANYTHING TO SMEAR, SLANDER,
BESMIRCH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
ANYBODY WHO LIKES THE PRESIDENT.
THAT MEANS THEY'RE ATTACKING
YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
ALL THESE HOLIER THAN THOU DIRT
BAGS TO BE OBVIOUS HERE, THEY'VE
WANTED PRESIDENT TRUMP IMPEACHED
PRETTY MUCH THE VERY MOMENT HE
WAS SWORN IN.
THEY HAVEN'T COME UP WITH ANY
REASON.
THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, IMPEACH,
IMPEACH, CONCLUSION, CONCLUSION.
STORMY, STORMY.
THERE WERE NO HIGH CRIMES,
BRIBERY, MISDEMEANORS, NO
CONSPIRACY, NO OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, NO COVER-UP AT ALL.
TONIGHT, NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
UKRAINIAN STORY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE ONLY PERSON THAT WAS THERE
SHAKING DOWN UKRAINE FOR
ANYTHING WAS SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY
JOE 30330.
COMING UP, THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEYS, JAY SECULA, RUDY
GIULIANI, THEY'LL BE HERE TO
WEIGH IN ON ALL OF THIS.
WE HAVE A STUDIO AUDIENCE PANEL
OF EXPERTS.
BUT FIRST, LET'S BE CLEAR AND
VERY CLEAR ABOUT ONE THING --
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT GOING TO BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
REMEMBER WHEN AL GREEN SAID,
BACK IN MAYE, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO IMPEACH HIM BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T WIN AT THE BALLOT BOX.
ALL OF THE HYSTERIA.
IT'S GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE UPSET
OVER IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT,
IN THE END WILL BE MUCH TO DO
ABOUT NOTHING.
THE DEMOCRATS, NANCY PELOSI, THE
JERRY NADLERS, THE SCHIFFTS, THE
MAXINE WATERS OF THE WORLD.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
PROCESS.
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE TO MAKE IT A
SAFER MORE SECURE COUNTRY,
CREATE JOBS, MORE PROSPERITY FOR
YOU, ME, WE, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS IS BEYOND A POLITICAL
STUNT.
THIS IS A PSYCHOSIS.
THEY CAN'T ESCAPE THE REALITY.
THEY LOST IN 2016.
IF THEY KEEP THIS UP, THEY'LL
LOSE BADLY IN 2020.
THIS IS A PARTY THAT DOES NOT
CARE ABOUT TRUTH.
THERE'S NO OBJECTIVE TRUTH IN
THEIR WORLD.
FACTS, JUSTICE, FAIRNESS, NONE
OF THAT MATTERS.
THEIR ONLY CONCERN IS LIKE A
BLOOD LUST FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
ANYBODY WHO SUPPORTS THE
PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT?
WELL, WE CAN'T SAY IT ANY BETTER
THAN HE HAS.
THIS, THEY, HAVE DECLARED WAR.
THEY DID IT.
SOMEBODY DECLARES WAR.
ONLY ONE ANSWER.
DEFEAT THEM IN THE -- AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'RE AT WAR, THESE PEOPLE
ARE SICK.
THEY'RE SICK.
AND NOBODY IS -- [INDISCERNIBLE]
>> Sean: A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
THE CALIFORNIA SICKNESS.
THE PRESIDENT CALLS HIM LITTLE
ADAM SCHIFF AND PENCIL NECK
SCHIFF.
WE REFER TO HIM AS THE BIGGEST
LIAR IN THE U.S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
CASE IN POINT, YESTERDAY HE
PERFORMED A DRAMATIC READING OF
THE PHONE CALL TRANSCRIPT
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT, HIS
COUNTERPART, ZALINSKI.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS HE MADE IT
UP.
EVERY SINGLE WORD HE MADE UP.
IN ORDER, AN OFFICIAL HOUSE
HEARING FEATURING AN ACTING
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE AND CONGRESSMAN SCH
INTELLIGENCE AND CONGRESSMAN S H
SCHFF, LIED, LIES, PROVEN A LIAR
ALL OVER AGAIN.
BUT OUT OF THIN AIR, WE HAD THE
TRANSCRIPT.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO MAKE IT UP.
HE COULD HAVE READ THE ACTUAL
TRANSCRIPT AND ENTERED THAT TO
THE OFFICIAL RECORD.
AFTER GETTING CALLED OUT FOR
LIAR, SCHIFF, YOU RECALL THE
FAKE VERSION OF THE PHONE CALL A
PARODY.
OH, THAT'S WHAT THAT IS IN
CONGRESS.
MAYBE HE'S RIGHT.
NOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOW
CALLING FOR HIM TO RESIGN.
HE TWEETED OUT, QUOTE, ADAM
SCHIFF TOTALLY MADE UP MY
CONVERSATION WITH THE UKRAINE
YAP PRESIDENT AND READ IT TO
CONGRESS AND MILLIONS.
HE MUST RESIGN.
HE MUST BE INVESTIGATED.
HE'S BEEN DOING IT FOR TWO
YEARS.
HE'S A SICK MAN.
AS PER USUAL, HE HAS NO REGRETS
FOR PURPOSEFULLY TRYING TO
MISLEAD THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
HE COULD HAVE READ IT THE WAY
THE TRANSCRIPT HAPPENED.
NO, HE NEEDED TO EMBELLISH IT,
BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
REAL TRANSCRIPT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU REGRET WHAT YOU CALL
THE PARODY, THE USE OF THOSE
PHRASES DURING THE COURSE OF
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT?
>> NO.
I THINK EVERYONE UNDERSTOOD AND
MY COLLEAGUES MAY SAY OTHERWISE
I WAS MOCKING THE PRESIDENT'S
CONDUCT.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT THIS,
WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID IS OF THE
UTMOST GRAVITY.
AND THE UTMOST SERIOUSnd BECAUSE
IT INVOLVES SUCH A FUNDAMENTAL
BETRAYAL OF HIS OATH.
>> >> Sean: THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME HE'S BEEN CAUGHT IN A
LIE.
BEFORE THE MUELLER REPORT WAS
RELEASED.
HE CLAIMED HE HAD DIRECT
EVIDENCE OF TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
LIE.
HE TOLD THAT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
ALSO CLAIMING OTHER EVIDENCE OF
CO-LEWDING, HIDING IN PLAIN
SIGHT.
ANOTHER LIE.
AND THERE'S AN ACTUAL RECORDING
OF SCHIFF, YEAH, HE'S THE ONE
GUY WHO BELIEVED HE WAS
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIAN.
AND IT WAS TAPED.
WHAT'S THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE.
NAKED PICTURE OF TRUMP.
DID VLADIMIR SEE IT?
OF COURSE, VLADIMIR SEE THE
NAKED PICTURES?
YEAH, HE WAS TRYING TO GET DIRT
ON DONALD TRUMP TO COLLUDE TO
IMPACT AMERICAN ELECTIONS.
SCHIFF WAS ENGAGING IN
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY, THE
DEMOCRATIC SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY,
PELOSI, IS FLOATING A BRAND NEW
BASELESS CONSPIRACY THEORY.
ACCORDING TO PELOSI, THE WHOLE
UKRAINE JANUSZ SHOE, RUSSIA IS
BEHIND THE PHONE CALL WITH THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
WOW, YOU KNOW, EARTH, PELOSI,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK RUSSIA HAS A HAND IN
THIS, BY THE WAY.
WE SAW THE DISRUPTION OF OUR
ELECTION LAST TIME.
THEY INTERFERED 100% CONFIDENCE
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
THE RUSSIANS DISRUPTED THE
ELECTIONS.
THAT WAS WRONG.
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
IS CENTRAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Sean: IT WAS RUSSIA'S FAULT,
OF COURSE.
NANCY, THE RUSSIA COLLUSION.
WE HAD FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS, HOUSE INTEL
INVESTIGATION, BIPARTISAN SENATE
INVESTIGATION, THE NINE-MONTH
FBI INVESTIGATION, THE MUELLER
3-YEAR WITCH HUNT.
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
NO OBSTRUCTION.
MAYBE SOMEONE SHOULD REMIND
NANCY THAT THE DEMOCRATS' FALSE,
PHONY, FEIGNED MORAL OUTRAGE IS
SHIFTED TO UKRAINE.
ON TO ANOTHER TALKING POINT.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP UP WITH YOUR
CROWD.
ALSO WE'RE LEARNING TONIGHT NEW
DETAILS THAT CAST VERY SERIOUS
DOUBT ON THE CLAIMS OF THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLEBLOWER THAT
ISN'T A WHISTLEBLOWER.
LOOK AT THIS.
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTER, KEN
VOGEL SAYING THAT THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE HAD NO IDEA THAT THE USA
WAS, YES, WITHHELD DURING THE
TRUMP PHONE CALL IN QUESTION.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW UNTIL A MONTH
LATER.
AND KEEP IN MIND, THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL FOUND THAT THE
WHISTLEBLOWER HAD POLITICAL BIAS
AGAINST TRUMP.
AND, REMEMBER, HE OR SHE WHO'S
NOT REALLY A WHISTLEBLOWER IS
REPRESENTED BY A LAW FIRM THAT
PAYS FOR ANTI-TRUMP LEAKS.
AND THE SO-CALLED WHISTLEBLOWER
WHO IS NOT KNOWN DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE OF ANY PHONE CALL,
THAT'S CALLS HEARSAY.
YOUR HONOR, I OBJECT, HEARSAY,
SUSTAINED.
THAT'S HOW THAT WOULD WORK IN A
COURT OF LAW.
THIRD-HAND ACCOUNTS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE IN THE MEDIA.
WELL, WHAT GOOD IS THAT?
THAT'S NOT A WHISTLEBLOWER.
WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ATTORNEY, JAY SECULA.
THEY'RE RIGHTLY CLAIMING THIS
PERSON DID NOT ACT ALONE.
IN FACT, JAY SECULA BELIEVES A
LAW FIRM DRAFTED THAT COMPLAINT.
CERTAINLY LOOKS LIKE IT TO ME.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A
WHISTLEBLOWER.
BUT ALSO ONE QUESTION TODAY IS,
WELL, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORT, FORMER CIA BACK TO THE
CIA?
OH, DO WE HAVE SPIES AGAIN
WITHIN OUR OWN GOVERNMENT SPYING
ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES?
ABUSING THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE WE GIVE THEM, WE
ENTRUSTED THEM TO KEEP US SAFE.
REGARDLESS OF WHO WROTE THE
COMPLAINT, THE CLAIMS WERE
BOGUS, THERE'S NO QUID PRO QUO.
ZIP, YOU CAN READ IT YOURSELF,
NOT THE MADE UP VERSION.
NO MISCONDUCT.
NOTHING, THE ONLY PERSON INVOLVE
IN A QUID PRO QUO IF YOU WANT TO
SAY SO, THAT WOULD BE, YEAH, JOE
30330 AND HIS SON WITH NO
QUALIFICATIONS.
WHEN IT COMES TO UKRAINE, NO
EXPERIENCE.
ENERGY, OIL, GAS, NO EXPERIENCE.
HE MAKES MILLIONS.
AND HE MADE BILLIONS IN CHINA.
SAME THING.
NO -- NO BACKGROUND EXPERIENCE
IN PRIVATE EQUITY, BANKING, NONE
WHATSOEVER.
THAT WE CAN FIND.
BUT HE GOES WITH HIS FATHER.
FLIES ON AIR FORCE 2, AND WHAT
DO YOU KNOW?
HE'S GOT $1.5 BILLION IN
CONTRACTS.
A GREAT LIFE IF YOUR DAD IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT, I GUESS.
SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY, NANCY
PELOSI IS LIVING IN HER
ALTERNATIVE REALITY EVEN
FURTHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO STAY
FOCUSED AS FAR AS THE PUBLIC IS
CONCERNED ON THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
USED TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO SHAKE
DOWN THE LEADER OF ANOTHER
COUNTRY FOR HIS OWN POLITICAL
GAIN.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN
HAVE?
THAT'S A QUID PRO QUO.
NANCY, CARE TO COMMENT ON THIS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE THE $1 BILLION.
THEY SAID, YOU HAVE NO
AUTHORITY.
YOU'RE NOT THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID I SHOULD CALL
HIM.
I SAID I'M TELLING YOU, YOU'RE
NOT GETTING THE $1 BILLION.
I SAID YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE $1
BILLION.
AISLE BE LEAVING HERE IN WHAT, I
THINK I SAID SIX HOURS.
IF THE PROSECUTOR IS NOT FIRED,
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE MONEY.
WELL SON OF A [ BLEEP ]
GOT FIRED.
>> Sean: SON OF A BEEP, THE GUY
INVESTIGATING MY SON DIDN'T HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE TO MAKE ALL OF
THAT MONEY, HE GOT FIRED BECAUSE
I THREATENED TO WITHHOLD TAX
DOLLAR, THE $1 BILLION WE WERE
GOING TO GIVE UKRAINE.
I'M IN CHARGE OF UKRAINE.
OKAY.
THAT'S BIDEN BRAGGING ABOUT
BREAKING THE LAW IN A QUID PRO
QUO.
TONIGHT THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT
THE FORMAL VICE PRESIDENT
LEVERAGED THE $1 BILLION.
YOU SAW THE TAPE OF YOUR MONEY
TO GET THE UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
FIRED ALL TO PROTECT HIS SON.
REMEMBER, IT WAS WORN BY "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" AND "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" TOLD THEM, YEAH,
THEY'RE INVESTIGATING YOUR SON.
ANOTHER WARNING.
HE TRIED PREVIOUSLY TO GET THE
GUY FIRED NOUCHLT HE JUST
WITHHELD THE $1 BILLION AND SAID
YOU HAVE SIX HOURS.
WHY WOULD THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
WANT A UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
FIRED?
NOW, JUST FOR A SECOND, BECAUSE
THE MEDIA WON'T TOUCH IT, LET'S
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND THAT THAT
WAS DONALD TRUMP BRAGGING THAT
HE WITHHELD THE $1 BILLION UNTIL
THEY FIRED A PROSECUTOR THAT WAS
DOING BUSINESS WITH HIS SONS OR
HIS DAUGHTERS.
I DON'T THINK THE MEDIA WOULD
EVER STOP UNTIL DONALD TRUMP GOT
IN TROUBLE FOR THAT LITTLE GIG.
BY THE WAY, DON JR., ERIC,
IVANKA, ANY -- TIFFANY, MAYHEM.
INSTEAD, THE MOB IS BARELY
COVERING THAT REAL SCANDAL,
SURROUNDING JOE AND HUNTER
BIDEN.
WE WON'T STOP.
WE'LL GET YOU THE TRUTH AS WE
ALWAYS DO.
THE TOP UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING, BARISMA HOLDINGS,
THAT'S THE OIL AND GAS COMPANY
THAT PAID HUNTER BIDEN MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO SERVE ON THEIR
BOARD AND CONSULT WITH NO
EXPERIENCE IN NATURAL GAS, NO
EXPERIENCE WITH UKRAINE.
AND AFTER LEARNING THAT HIS SON
WAS ABOUT TO BE INTERVIEW BED I
THE TOP PROSECUTOR, WELL, THAT'S
WHEN, WELL, SLEEPY JOE, 30330
DEMANDED THE PROSECUTOR BE
FIRED.
BIDEN SAID HE WANTED THE
PROSECUTOR BE GOB BECAUSE HE WAS
CORRUPT.
WE HAVE A BRAND NEW REPORT FROM
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER, JOHN
SOLOMON.
BIDEN'S STORY DOESN'T HOLD
WATER.
450 BRAND NEW DOCUMENTS, PAGES
OF IT.
INTERVIEWS, NUMEROUS UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS AND IT APPEARS THE
PROSECUTOR WAS FIRED BECAUSE OF
PERSONAL REASONS SURROUNDING THE